Emma got unique was made from this
special method from the heart of a dying
star and when I spun it really really
fast it gave me the ability to fly
Rhoda Hema no I didn't ride down the hem
are you on your Beck no no I spin it
really fast and if it would pull me off
oh my god am i pulled off the ground
pulled me off the ground up into the air
and I would fly every time I threw he'll
always come back to me sounds like you
had a pretty special and intimate
relationship with this hammer and then
losing it was almost comparable to
losing a loved one it's a nice way of
putting it
welcome voice activation required for on
November 3rd access denied god of
thunder
tonight Prince of Asgard strongest
eventually let me try banner welcome
strongest Avenger Oh what thor ragnarok
rated pg-13 in theatres November 3rd yet
tickets now the hell is the goddess of
death and I've had incredible fun
playing that Oh miss tell us the first
female villain that we've had in the
Marvel film and Kate has destroyed the
idea of your typical villain kneel
before your queen cate blanchett I was
so excited to see what she was gonna do
hello has this insane off-kilter
attitude you know like a smart boy how
would you like a job
I think the best villains are always
those that you kind of love and hate
what they do but you sort of understand
it there's a logic to it she wants to
come back home and be accepted and she
wants what says you're in my seat I
would love for someone else to rule but
it can't be you you're just the worst
some of the happiest times have been
fading people out I've really enjoyed us
like I don't speak today I can just
throw axes in - someone's got good